لقد قطعت وعدًا لـ Biesheim
لعبة آنا قافية تساعد من أنا
على قيد الحياة والصوت هو ما في بلدي
عروق وأود أن نوبي hannachi و
عندما استلمت هذه الجائزة الخميس 20 مايو
من أجلك لأنني لديك شجاع
هل يقومون بتحديث البيع في
بعبارة أخرى خطر وأخيرا إذا كنت
كل شيء يقع لي
استقبلها لك وأنا أقول لك
من خلال الشعور بوجودها دائمًا
معي نعم نعم أنا نفس الشيء
لا يزال بالأمس
[موسيقى]
م
إبراهيم العساف ما زلت ألعب
ضباب
أنفسهم المباراة
[موسيقى]
حكم واود منك ان تذهب
m la morbihannaise كل شيء j mr يقول كل شيء
شرحت وابتسمت لي
زوجي السويسري اليومي ثلاثة أيام
بعد ذلك كنت أحلم حقا سيئا للغاية ولكن
انها حقا لن تتحدث عنه
شيء لا شيء وبقي
لتقرحات ماما القصة الآن
عليك أن تدير
أحتاجك ليس لدي
عادة كان دائما
شجاع
استيقظت وأؤكد لكم أنهم
تريد أن يتم إلقاؤها في تلك اللحظة من
ارتفاع الأسعار كذلك
والجينز
كثيرا ما تقطعت بهم السبل في البحرين
كانت بعيدة عن 60 مباراة اليوم
[موسيقى]
عرضت معالجات الحقائب ل
كان الدليل في هذه الصالة الرياضية أنا
بحثت عن حقائبه وسنة أو نحو ذلك
شيء مكتوب ووجدت المؤامرة
بدون إلهي أنا قوي جدا ولكن
عرفت كيف تتوقف عند هؤلاء النساء
المزيد ترجم إلى صالة للألعاب الرياضية وحيث
مرور السيارات وكنت أساعد بلدي
يا بني ، غالبًا ما يذهبون إلى هناك هذا على واحد فقط
بعض الوقت وهذه هي الطريقة
ذهبت إلى تولوز قابلت هؤلاء
الشباب جمهورية لدينا
المجتمع لا يريد لنا لا
محظوظ لأنه ابتعد بكاميراته
على العكس من ذلك يتم حبسهم
خلف عمري للأسف
بعض الناس الذين لا يعرفون
التاريخ و jus man الاسلام
مرت من أجل السلام وإساءة معاملتهم
للأسف يقول موينير الذي يصنع
خطأ في العالم وهذا ما يتطلبه الأمر
الذي تغلبنا عليه اليوم ولكن ليس بتسعة
يجب علينا أيضًا مساعدتهم على الخروج منه
هناك لأن هؤلاء الشباب نفس الاسم في هذا
8 القطاع يعاني أيضا من الشعور
أنهم يؤذون الآخرين وهذا هو
جميل يفوز معهم اليوم و
ليوجههم الخرف وسيمون
شاربونو نعرف كيف يمكننا ذلك
العمل مع هؤلاء الشباب لأن هؤلاء
الشباب الأكفاء الذين دانتك
أسباب تتعهد الفقر
التعليم أو خداع والديه الذين يريدون ذلك
نقابته وهو أمر خطير للغاية و
عظيم
jb ندف كان سيئ الحظ
تنجح وجيناته كما خسر
أمل مع الجميع وعبر
لا أحد يكذب ببطء من
الدين سيء
لسوء الحظ لأنه في أيام السبت الساعة
ذلك وداخلها في فرنسا التي أسسها
ذلك وهو أمر مؤسف لأنه متى
كل gmao كل العرب الخطرين
ليس هذا هو الحال على ما أعتقد
العمل مع هؤلاء الشباب ونعم هذا
لم يعد على الإطلاق هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين لديهم
أنت تسيء فهم وما يضعونه
هناك
في المساء ، كل شيء هناك
للعديد من المعجبين الذين لاحظوا ذلك
مع الغراء في البداية و loomis
هذا يضع روح السد في قطر
[موسيقى]
هذا هو الأخير الخاص بك